hello and welcome to this video playing
PL o-- grinder so just this feels pretty
comfortable for black good center early
on age six balls play to prevent Bishop
g5 the bishop here doesn't have a clear
spot maybe why should consider some f4
interesting i hear you can take this and
ask black about how he gets the pawn
back you will get it back very likely or
we should be six or d 4d for is a bit
more a bit sharper it's also nothing
wrong about this so maybe this is what i
do what do i want to take with the
bishop IAM trade trade this strong piece
it looks a bit slow ish well it is a
strong piece so why not
yeah I think I've got a pretty
comfortable equality not much more that
definitely no problems to have an
interesting question do I want to take
on c3 and trade a bit of structure
against the bishop I think I do that
just form to have some imbalance in the
position and maybe Queen d5 was actually
interesting hmm crime yeah definitely 25
was interesting
again add a head 25 it's something that
I probably should have considered a
little bit more carefully 26 I don't
know rook the eight is a bit awkward fam
okay so i don't know before a six not
sure so i have night before as well won
95-94 is interesting
check spectre-2 d5 now I Scott night a
five as well huh now that wasn't all
that great and the night was good on c6
that was a bad idea night before and so
on i should have just to have just kept
it on c6 giving black a very easy good
position and this isn't this isn't so
clear now badly played just not good
taking on five I always thought is
questionable due to rook e8 but it's got
this stupid 26 move now I play a
playtest bad name Queen d6 maybe I can
play Queen a form
and rookie to this even 94 I'm just too
just bad bad bad game we're looking all
kinds of stupid things easier things
okay
especially knowing as white was like in
this position white is essentially
already out plate but I just played a
terribly bad game from them
[Music]
and okay maybe it's still kind of
interesting night here or something add
some trickery here maybe 92 doesn't do
anything maybe I can try to like swing
the rook over to h5 and all of a sudden
get some miraculous king at King side
attack would be kind of strange but time
morning that probably is completely
offered anyway
it's not easy 92 some before then or you
for still works and it's just I just
Campbell this I don't really know if it
works here c7 G d7 was a move check
check I'm can't I pin no haha I know
haha ok black resigns yeah just just
when I was back in the game I think I
know it's it actually loses but I had a
win certainly I looked you three wins
and it looked at it looked like there
should be something group 231 yeah and
then we get you one I just I just
completely forgot that check that cuz
there's a pin and otherwise like Queen
III and drew cage for is made but if I
kick it's not G it that it wasn't it was
a really bad game especially I made a
complete a total mistake by night before
this disposition is fantastic for black
this is just a very nice position and
you should not really do anything like
night before and so on as the engine
says like a 595 a for this is
strategically extremely nice the night
is good on c6 I was tempted by someone
whatever yeah some checks or so and
I'm just miss placing my pieces this is
very bad the night the night is good on
c6 it should never move really should
never move and by now it's it's totally
I mean it's it's probably unclear but I
just hated that I'm in this position I
mean it simply shouldn't happen simply
shouldn't happen it's still reasonably
complicated and yeah somehow this is the
stuff paid off for four chance 95 seems
to be playable I was just gambling that
I have something I didn't calculate it
and he looked you three and would have
one funny enough yeah like this this and
then generate a exam no I just saw the
other thing and thought okay I'm winning
and I wasn't it okay thanks for watching